Tucker Carlson just this past week was
averaging 3.3 million viewers meaning
Fox News lost nearly half of Their
audience when they got rid of Tucker
Carlson and uh okay I think Tucker is
happy I saw a video of him riding around
in a golf course a golf cart with his
wife laughing so he's probably like
great I can start my own company make a
ton of money
here's what gets interesting though if
we jump down to the key demo viewership
take a look at this if we go to the 8 PM
Fox News Tonight 149
000 viewers in the key demo Anderson
Cooper and MSNBC both beat Fox News that
is just laughably embarrassing I mean
look at this Jesse Waters beats both CNN
and MSNBC and then at 8 pm CNN and MSNBC
beat Fox News Chris Hayes has beaten Fox
News
embarrassing